[Music]
everywhere i go
i see his face i just really miss him
yeah i miss him too i don't think tony
would have done what he did
if he didn't know that you were gonna be
here after he was gone
you gonna be the next iron man now well
no i don't have time i'm too busy doing
your jobs
oh i'm kidding i'm kidding look keep up
the good work because i
am going on vacation
heads up nick fury's calling you i don't
really want to talk to nixon
phone why because if you don't talk to
them and i have to talk i want to talk
to them
you sent nick fury to voicemail i gotta
go you do not ghost nick fury
what up dorks what's up we're just
talking about the trip i'm here in saint
marco polo
oh i think mj really likes me everyone's
been when i first went alone
you're a very difficult person to
contact
spider-man
this is mr beck who could have used
someone like you on my world
new world beck is from earth just not
ours the snap to our hole in our
dimension
you're saying there's a multiverse we
have a job to do
you're coming with us
there's got to be someone else you can
use what about thor off world
captain marvel unavailable
but i'm just a friendly neighborhood
spider-man
[Music]
[ __ ] please you've been to space what
do you want peter
i want to go back on my trip with the
girl who i really like and tell her how
i feel
mj i am spider-man no
of course i'm not i mean it's kind of
obvious
you're right you may not be ready but
this is my responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
oh my god just always feel like i'm
putting my friends in danger
the world needs next iron man
you're going to step up or
[Music]
i not get you guys out of here get on
the jet who are you i work with
spider-man you work for spider-man i
work with spider-man not for spider-man
new plan
[Music]
thomas alva edison
my boys and i caught in a jar but before
now is only flashed across the night sky
the future is here hello
i'm george westinghouse nicola tesla
i will be the greatest provider of
electrical power in the world better
than edison
there's a contest between you this is a
battle for the brightest minds of
america
today the impossible becomes possible
the man that controls that current
controls the future
i hope you brought your checkbooks if
you want to be remembered it's simple
shoot a president but if you prefer to
have what i call a legacy you
leave the world a better place than you
found it
you are building miracles out of thin
air i'm working on something
so new that the world would never be the
same if mr edison succeeds he will set
us back so far we may never
recover sometimes we have to work
outside of the rules to get what's right
that is how you truly win you got
vultures in every venture but uh
did i mention that his system's lethal
his
current kills people
he's playing dirty you can't too
you can't see the real force that moves
things and it's not ac dc it's not
currents
it's a currency this is costing us a
ford's question house
stole from me my motor
that is our future
you're fired you're never going to be
anything named tesla ever again
our future's not going to be paved with
bricks but with copper
i have the better system westinghouse
electric shall endure
a city of light i built it already in my
imagination and it is perfect
there is a possibility you'll be putting
in jeopardy the lives of 28 million
people
tonight things could change should we go
for a ride
three two one
only one man will rise
so what's your trade inventor fix
problems for idiots
i guess it's time to introduce myself
[Music]
just three ounces of pressure to the
vagus nerve and then
look at your boy sleepy night night
lance sterling a legendary spy who's
always dressed to impress
walter beckett graduated mit at 15
and works in the tech innovations lab
there are so many gadgets i want to test
in the field
for example the inflatable hug
kind of a personal protection device
i've been developing
[Music]
this is a vile waste of taxpayer dollars
this is your next objective none of our
agents can get close to him
[Music]
i have something that can help it's
called biodynamic concealment
imagine if i can make you disappear
[Music]
hey lance look at me look at you i can
see
my butt and your face at the same time
that is so cool
being a pigeon can make you an even
better spy
pigeons are everywhere and nobody
notices them
in fact pigeons can see in slow motion
that was tight did anyone else see a um
a pigeon and pigeons can fly up to 92
miles per hour
don't you throw me off this roof
he'll figure it out
all right gamora starting it's about to
get messy time to go sleepy night night
i miss my hands i gotta stay
we have different skill sets that's what
makes us such a great team
wealthy you're squeezing too
what happens in the submarine stays in
the submarine
you are the explorer give me a hand
don't be afraid your dream
to be in a forest i wish to find a lost
city
what you seek is far greater
than you ever imagined
your soul will never be quiet until you
find this place
it is your destiny
there's a major exploration of foot
terrible disease
murders savages the journey may well
mean your life
don't go he'll not know you when you
return i know this is a sacrifice for
all of us
but it won't be worth it a man's reach
should exceed his grasp
i am proposing that amazonia contain a
hidden
civilization if we may
find a city where one was considered
impossible to exist
it may well write a whole new chapter
in human history are you insisting that
these savages
they are equals their civilization may
well predate our own
i call it set the ultimate piece of the
human puzzle
i strongly advise you to abort the
mission it's become far too
dangerous you must turn back
there is no turning back
i stay here and struggle to provide for
the children while you wander the jungle
you don't care about us you don't even
care about going home
you only care about your lost city
this search for zed i can no longer bear
the cost
you've come to doubt its existence no
i only doubt that said provide all the
answers you seek from it
[Music]
happy birthday mr adult man oh my
god what was dad like
his beard was scratchy he had a goofy
laugh i wish i'd met him
[Music]
i have something for you from your dad
it's a wizard staff
i wrote this spell so i could see for
myself who my boys grew up to be
this spell brings him back back like
back to life
he wanted to meet you more than anything
holy tooth of zadar how did you i don't
know it just started
hang on
dad you are in your house
we've only got 24 hours to bring back
the rest of dad
we're going on a quest
all quests start with the manticore the
fearless adventurer you mean
corey she's over there quick somebody
help me these griffin nuggets were
supposed to go out minutes ago that's
the man's decor
you guys are in trouble big time get in
the vehicle i'm escorting you home i'm
giving you to the count of three
uh okay wait what are you doing i don't
know
oh they went on a quest but don't worry
i told them about the map i told them
about the gym i told them about the
curse
huh i forgot to tell them about the cars
what
your boys are in great danger
[Applause]
[Applause]
i can't do it we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this
i believe in you my gut knows where to
go don't you boy yes you do
i'm on my way boys just stay out of
trouble
[Music]
[Music]
the entire time i knew him he only ever
had one
goal
to wipe out half the universe
if he gets all the infinity stones he
can do it with the snap of his fingers
just like that tell me his name again
thanos
[Music]
we got one advantage he's coming to us
we have what thanos wants so that's what
we use
[Music]
let's talk about this plan years i think
it's good except
it sucks so let me do the plan and that
way it might be really good
wow
the end is near
when i'm done
[Music]
half of humanity will still exist
perfectly balanced
as all things should be
i hope they remember you
[Music]
i'm peter by the way doctor strange oh
i'm using your made up names then i am
spiderman
[Music]
oh
[Music]
we were headed for the edge of sanity
[Music]
like we were apparitions phantoms
[Music]
trust gave way to doubt
[Music]
hope to superstition
[Music]
the tragedy of the essex is the story of
men
[Music]
and demons
you have any idea what could happen you
out here
[Music]
hey you sure you're good with this i got
this
you know if you're interested i could
talk to my guys down at the warehouse
see if they could use a hand i'm good
thanks did
some of you just don't get it i know you
know have fun
how come you love mom you guys are the
best thing in my life
what it's pretty much the only thing i
haven't screwed up yet
come here i'm
sorry i yelled either you ever shot one
of these before
what if i took your boys out yeah say
yes
uh yeah sure
i know it's cool ted gave us a card for
emergencies and stuff
this is not an emergency
where's my phone i'm gonna spend some
time with you i don't want your phone to
get all the attention
all right
you drive let me try you can see over
the steering wheel
[Applause]
my mom can't find out about this no i
don't think
he'd let us hang out anymore no no
no i just can't let that happen
[Music]
look there's a cabin down there
[Music]
what is that
do you know what he's doing whoa what
are you doing here
tonight in the cabin we were here first
where's my dad where'd he go i don't
know
where's the other guy look i'm your
father
it's my job to protect you
do something to him what was he talking
about stick together
god he doesn't want to leave
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you